j'ai demandé lundi quand ils se sont
rués sur moi et mon avec le témoignage
poignant mots durs discours plein
d'émotion
les écrivains persécutés racontent leur
histoire les élèves de seconde et de
première du lycée deux villas roy a cuit
en cours sont attentifs et prennent des
notes
c'est une expérience quand même que nous
on pourra pas vivre et qu'on veut qu'on
vivra sûrement pas donc ils nous ont
apporté leur expérience personnelle ému
les élèves découvrent le vécu de rémy
ngono journalistes camerounais persécuté
pour avoir dénoncé la corruption dans
son pays et de golan
à j-1 poète kurdes syriens témoin de la
persécution en syrie j'ai été émue par
la persévérance des écrivains et tous
genres ils sont persécutés mais il
continue pas mais je trouve ça ça
vraiment bon une rencontre riche non
seulement pour les élèves mais aussi
pour les écrivains pour moi je suis
curieux de savoir des ces avis les de
ces générations qu'un jeu je discute ces
idées avec le public jeune je me trouve
à quelques fois comme des surprises
parce que je pendant 7
échange je me trouvais dans un autre
endroit de pour penser de ces idées très
important dans notre époque